uh let me introduce you first okay
um welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speakers
speaker invited speaker let's go over
some rules and Logistics uh first of all
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to a mute and
ask otherwise please use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q a session at the end
gdps seminar is open to external
audiences
um therefore no classified this question
is allowed so please watch out finally
The Talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel that's
about it now let me introduce our
speaker today it is an honor to host
Andrea Mangione who is an associate
professor of numerical analysis at
Polytechnic the Milano Italy since 2020
he received the master's degree in
mathematical engineering from Polytech
the Milano in 2008 where he is now a
faculty there and the PHD in mathematics
from the Eco Polytech Federal the epfl
the Switzerland in 2012. he is the
author of three books and of about 70
papers he won the numerous Awards
including e-commerce and the Siam Awards
his research interests focus on reduced
total modeling techniques for pdes
machine learning and deep learning PD
constraint optimization and uncertainty
quantification with several applications
including fluid dynamics cutting cardiac
Electro physiology computational
mechanics and the structural health
monitoring today Andrea will talk about
deep learning for reduced Auto modeling
which is a very interesting topic please
enjoy and expect a wonderful talk now
without further Ado let me pass the
button to Andrea by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question is
can you think of the biggest sacrifice
you have made in your life to be where
you are right now
have to say have to say give me maybe
half an hour 40 minutes after the talk
maybe I will be back to your question
all right
for this very kind invitation I'm very
happy to to to to be here I mean of
course only only remotely connected uh
it's really night here in in almost
night evening quite even in in Milano
Italy uh yeah my talk is about deep
learning for how to disorder modeling
this will be somehow a story of about
our research carried out in the last two
years two years and a half and before
starting of course I would like to say
acknowledge I mean the people that
actually shared this uh this journey
about deep learning and research the
modeling first of all Stefania Fresca uh
postdoc with me here at Mark's
polytechnicolores Franco he also is a
junior postdoc with Chichi now moved to
London is researcher in another
department at the civil engineering
department here in Milano and Paulo
County now currently PhD student uh um
under my co-supervision and the
supervision of another colleague that is
attilio frangi food professor in civil
engineering uh Department Paul zinino uh
uh colleague and dear friend of mine uh
also uh for Professor here of numerical
analysis at mocks and then mango guo
from University of 20
um is assistant professor there and Jana
staven is for professor at tpfl Los
Angeles in the three parts of the talks
the contribution uh I've uh had the
honor to share with these people will
somehow will somehow appear
um of course I I I don't need I guess to
convince you that in in several cases in
several scenarios what we need is uh uh
good in sense of accurate and efficient
resistor modeling error I am the
disorder modeling uh is key is essential
to to allow real-time simulation uh data
simulation uncertainty quantification
towards also the the construction of of
predictive digital twins uh no matter if
you are dealing with say that the
support to clinical decisions or to
structural ad monitoring or also to
designing and Manufacturing sooner or
later you need to carry out say
efficient and accurate numerical
simulation often or very complex systems
so the two questions I would like to
address uh this evening this morning
with you is whether or not scientific
machine learning can enhance somehow
reduce order modeling some of these are
the modeling is a very active research
field for the last I would say at least
20 years but of course new tools and new
algorithms and new ideas from say
scientific machine learning at large can
somehow enhance and I would like to show
you at least some cases in which we are
able to enhance the disorder modeling by
using scientific machine learning of
course on the other hand how do deep
learning algorithms impact on the
accuracy and the efficiency of reduced
reduced order models so before starting
the global picture of course
a lot of approaches have been say
appeared in the last say few years
regarding say both physics based and
data are driven a methods and I've tried
to somehow co-locate them on a on a line
by looking at the top you have of course
reduced basis methods or small
projection based techniques to perform a
reduced order modeling I will give you
in in a while a very quick introduction
to this
of course in this case you still need to
to solve low dimensional uh possibly
nonlinear dynamical systems to get the
solution by going say down say you you
you find an intrusive reduce basis
methods you somehow try to still rely on
say maybe subspaces or linear subspaces
but to to carry out the construction of
ROMs in a in a less intrusive or
possibly non-intrusive non-intrusive
ways and then you also have for sure
physics in four neural network in which
the contribution of the say data-driven
say way to to build say of course
ensuring the Fulfillment of physical
constraints but the use of neural
networks in that case becomes more more
and more relevant uh we are somehow
um in the middle uh because what I
wonder what would you like to to talk
okay are non-linear say strategies
relying on deep learning to construct
reduced
um order models and then the ingredients
I will rely on
are fit for one neural networks out
encoders and somehow I will also touch a
little bit uh on say a new way of
dealing with machine formed uh neural
networks these are some of the keywords
that I I will use say during during the
presentation
um of course the the the picture is
quite is quite big in my opinion we we
for sure are interested to develop say a
disorder modeling relying on machine
learning and deep learning we could also
perform a sort of algorithmic
augmentation by Machine learning and
deep learning somehow trying to replace
those parts of our user model that
represent a computational bottlenecks we
would also be interested in performing a
sort of data-driven learning of physical
laws even if I will not say address this
topic
um today
we want us to perform a certain
quantification once we have reduced
other model and last but not least we
would also say rely on approximation
Theory to ensure that mathematically
speaking what we have built is say
accurate in the sense of some say error
estimates and so on of course at the
core at the the middle we have physical
models in the form of partial
differential equations or say dynamical
systems in terms of audience
and these are some tasks that we usually
face not just we but say are quite big
like a big research Community all over
the world are trying to somehow face of
course to perform model Discovery or
data simulation regarding say the
learning of physical laws to approximate
the solution to a given physical problem
maybe register their modeling
construction using using neural Nets uh
or also to take into account information
and contributions that can come from
different models with different
fidelities so now the the three keywords
that I have highlighted in blue will be
somehow the the three pillars of my
presentation I will first address say
possible ideas to perform the
approximation of the whole solution of
the problem and then I will move to say
a possible way to exploit that those
ideas also to perform operator
approximation and last but not least how
to take into account say neural networks
to perform also the approximation of
some output quantities of interest in a
multi-fidelity framework uh so these are
all say the the connections we have some
applications uh in mind I will show you
results regarding these four uh classes
of problems
um computational mechanics cardiac
electrophysiology and then fluid
dynamics and also uh some few results
regarding say
microelectromechanical mechanical
systems the the keywords are somehow in
the middle of this slide so I will first
address ideas regarding a deep learning
based reducer other models and then I
will move to a sort of newer Technique
we call it the pyramnet how to take into
account say neural networks to perform
operator approximation and last but not
least multi-fidelity neural network
regression so this will be somehow the
outline of of my talk so for the first
part I will focus on deep learning based
uh reduce order models uh before a
couple of words about say a classical
way a more classical way to construct
reduce order models that is projection
based reducer their models I guess many
of you have already experienced with
redis order modeling and in particular
disorder modeling of parameterized
systems or equations that depends on
physical or geometrical parameters
sooner or later you need to replace a
full order model with something that is
more more efficient but still still
accurate of course full order models for
us are quite a huge say quite large
dimensional dynamical systems we want to
approximate the solution in time for
many different parameter values and this
means that we have say time derivatives
and then linear and non-linear operators
and for for the sake of Simplicity I
will already rely on a discretized
version think about planet elements or
your best say your more favorites a
discretization
space then we end up with a quite large
scale dynamical system to solve
projection-based reduces modeling
somehow relies on low dimensional linear
subspaces we can use for instance proper
orthogonal decomposition that is nothing
but singular value the composition on a
given Matrix of snapshots of the of the
form to to build say a low dimensional
hopefully low dimensional linear
Subspace in which we then look for for
the solution we assume in this case that
the say form solution uh is approximated
by a linear combination of say few basis
functions or reduced bases these are
capital N hopefully the dimension of
these reduce basis is much smaller than
the dimension NH of the of the initial
High Fidelity space and then through a
gallery projection or a more General
petrogalarkin projection we end up with
a disorder model that looks like the one
in the in the green box so now this
shares the same structure of the of the
full order model but now the dimension n
is much smaller than an H of course we
need to take care of the assembling of
the efficient assembling of The
Operators that appear in this reducer
the model and this is the reason why we
need to rely on suitable hyper reduction
techniques this is somehow say the the
the global picture regarding say
projection based disorder models of
course there are some say
um pros and cons
in these says in this context we we can
compute the whole Fields variable
quickly then we we can evaluate any
possible output quantities of interest
that depend on that solution of course
sometimes they are sampling of of the
reduced order model might become even
more expensive than its solution and
this is of course a a true computational
bottleneck and last but not least even
more crucially often some problems are
not reducible mathematically speaking
those problems that show as low decay of
the cold mugarh with or say more hardly
reducible by means of this this kind of
of techniques this is an example this is
a somehow motivating example uh arising
in cardiac electrophysiology we have a
non-linear unsteady reaction diffusion
problem uh the variable that you that
you look on the on the movie even if
they are a bit lagged unfortunately is
the electric potential this is a very
simple test case a two-dimensional say
portion of tissue in which you have
three parameters the time at which you
deliver say a second stimulus to to the
tissue that the radius of the region in
which you you release the stimulus and
some recovery properties of the tissue
so
um just three parameters are enough to
make the picture quite involved because
you may have very different say uh
results in terms of the say evolution of
the of the electrical potential here you
have some say
um
snapshots in in time and two different
parameter values on the half of the
slides you have the full order model on
the right you have the registered model
so everything seems to be good but the
issue is related with the slow decay of
the singular values related with both
the solution snapshots and the snapshots
of the non-linear operators that appear
into the problem so even if say the
accuracy is is good the point is that by
relying also on local reduced basis you
you need quite large reduced bases and
these of course affect the efficiency of
a resource and modeling in in these
context and last but not least even in
presence of local reduced basis spaces
ROMs might be not very well suited to to
problems that feature coherent
structures that propagate over time so
you can also say end up with issues
related with the stability in in long
time intervals on this kind of of
methods so the reduced Dimension can be
potentially not as small as desired this
is another drop back
iPad induction uh is costly is an
intrusive say task and these can prevent
the ROMs from being very efficient and
say even more importantly a ROM built in
in this way must account for all the
variables that are that are involved in
in the in the Florida model for instance
in this case the electric potential is
not the only say variable like for
instance in the Navy stocks equations
you have velocities and pressure and if
you want to rely on poskin ROMs you you
need to to approximate both velocity and
pressure
and and these are some of the drawbacks
of these these techniques and then we we
started to look at this problem for from
a slight different perspective
um somehow say noting that the
similarity as say many other of course
authors and groups did somehow that
there's a close similarity between say
uh proper orthogonal decomposition that
in a way is already a a task that say
allows a sort of encoding and then a
decoding because when you have say the
low dimensional approximation of the
solution use amount decoded to get say
the High Fidelity approximation of
course this is a linear operation in the
case of pod this is just a matrix by
Vector multiplication and the same to to
pass from The High Fidelity space to the
low dimensional space and somehow
encoders can in a way generalize this
kind of encoding decoding as soon as
they are say applied to snapshots of the
full order model so somehow we start
from data that are generated from the
floater model these are snapshots data
and we we try to see if indeed relying
on auto encoders possibly involved in
convolutional layers can say enhance
this reduction task
uh somehow the latent representation
that is provided by another encoder
hopefully is much uh lower dimensional
than the one provided by pod of course
this is obtained through a non-linear
model test that has to be learned so
this is a way say a sort of parallelism
between pod on the left and then out
encoders on the right but this is just
one of the two tasks that we have
because this is just a way to to
represent our reduced reduced order
solution the the other task is to
somehow be able to replace the
generation of of the reduce order model
and there is that the first idea we we
started from so deep learning based
reduced order models in a way couple two
different architectures that can be
trained both say simultaneously or say
separately so a convolutional auto
encoder the part that you look here in
you you have it here in in light blue
you start from High Fidelity data and
then by using also some convolutional
layers use somehow compress the
information that is contained on those
data as you say treat images when you
need to compress say Imaging data Say by
by buyout encoders this is only one part
because the second part is a
forward neural network that from the
time and the parameter Vector mu allows
us to generate a low dimensional
representation of the solution so during
the training phase what we actually do
is to train both networks by taking into
account the snapshots
of the problem uh say we we want to
solve for say times and parameter uh
values we compute snapshots data and
then we somehow match not just say the
the the gray part somehow uh the data
after the say encoding and the decoding
must look as close as possible to that
the initial data but also say the low
dimensional representations that here is
uh is uh given as as output from from
the encoder must match say the outcome
of the deep fit photo neural network
because during the so-called online
phase during the testing stage what we
want is just say to to rely on what is
here contained in this red block and for
any new time and new parameter value we
only want to evaluate say the
composition of two neural networks to
Simply say get these low dimensional
representation and then decode these two
say get the representation in the in the
High Fidelity space so to be slightly
more technical uh we need to perform two
tasks we need to perform uh the learning
of the reduced Dynamics uh and to say
learn the Dynamics of the system on
these reduced non-linear trial manifold
we use at Deep fit forward narrow
network of course these are some options
I don't want to say these are the only
options these are somehow the options we
we found quite quite quite convenient uh
and the second task is the learning of
the non-linear trial manifold because we
want to model say somehow the
traditional linear trial manifold
through the decoder function of a
convolutional out encoder and the
composition say of this decoder end of
the deep foreign neural network is what
at the end of the day provides the
dlrama proximation
so uh online at the very end we say
compute the dlm approximations by say
evaluating two Nets that have been
trained these are trained offline and
the training of these nets requires the
solution of an optimization problem
where say the loss function is made by
those two contributions that appeared
before before in the slide the sort of
say reconstruction error and a sort of
say
closing close match between say the the
low dimensional representation provided
by the encoder and the Deep feed
Foreigner Network all the details of
course are available in the papers and
these are collected at the end of the
presentations but of course feel free
then to contact me if you have say
further question and then more details
say questions on any aspect I will I
will cover now some results regarding on
a two-dimensional uh no linear diffusion
reaction problem as the one I showed you
before here you have the full order
model this is the DL ROM solution with a
latent Dimension equal to three here we
have two parameters that are the
coordinates of the stimulus that is
released say in this small portion of
tissue plus time and this is not my
chance that we have decided through to
fix to 3 the reduced Dimension the
comparison is uh clearly in favor of
this deep learning based reducer models
this only takes a less than two seconds
on a CPU and less than half a second on
a GPU to get the new a solution for a
new say choice of the parameter values
again say that the 14 seconds periodical
Larkin ROM or eight seconds
relying on on local reduced basis
function this is of course are an
initial say test case here you have a
slightly more challenging example where
you some hours in this case changing say
the the location of the position where
you release these these second stimulus
in this once again no linear reaction
diffusion problem and those in this case
the comparison is between the 15 seconds
a deal ROM takes online to run and to
perform say the approximation on CPU
less than a couple of seconds and a GPU
against more than say six minutes for
for the form and say uh one minute and a
half or half a minute for say uh aguiler
can run
and here you have also the the behavior
of the error on the testing on on the
testing set say in time and the error
stays of course under the desired Thresh
um so just a couple of slides now for
commenting maybe a bit more uh these
aspects related on the choice of these
uh reduced or latent Dimension and of
course in the case of pod we clearly
have say indication from the decay of
the singular values where to say uh
truncate or to chop the Pod expansion
but how to perform this in the case of
deep learning uh base redis order models
where we uh took inspiration from some
works by the war and co-authors of some
some years ago somehow introducing and
then taking advantage of our sort of
non-linear extension of the kolmogoro
and width that the usual say a
mathematical concept that is say used to
evaluate the reducibility when you rely
on linear subspaces
um we somehow have that in the case of a
say architecture like the one I showed
you before here notation is slightly
different because you have say an
encoder because I prime sorry a decoder
PSI and then this fit folder Nano
Network Phi well it is possible at least
for say uh linear uh elliptic PDS we
started from say linear electric PDS it
is possible to show that say depending
on the number P of the parameters that
are involved in the problem we can
somehow bound or also somehow try to to
compare how these say latent Dimension
must behave and for instance if the
parameter to solution map is say
fulfilling some regularity assumptions
you can also show that say these latent
Dimension can be chosen as mean equal to
the number of the of the parameters uh
and the the details of those results are
reported in this say uh recently
accepted on map mathematics of
computation paper
that is that is say highlighted
highlighted here
this is a one part say of the result
containing that paper the second part is
also related with a sort of say
guidelines to construct those
architectures so assuming that once
again some regularity assumptions are
are fulfilled regarding the parameters
solution map
we can say link say the the accuracy in
terms of a tolerance Epsilon we have say
on the two error contributions we we
have to bound the sort of reconstruction
error and the sort of parametric error
we can somehow ensure that the error is
below under a given threshold and as a
function of this threshold we can also
say
assess how many for instance active
weights and layers must be considered
the in both say the the out encoder and
the feed forward neural network so that
there's of course say an ongoing
activity on the generalization of this
kind of say results also to to other
kind of of architectures uh but uh we
started some hours to uh to to to
provide a sort of say mathematical say
um uh theoretical uh ground on on this
of course this is not the the entire
story because if it is true that the
dimension of the deep learning reduce
order models can be kept very small uh
hopefully say equal to the number of the
parameters that are involved it is also
true that the DL ROM can be queried at
any desired time I don't need to solve
any dynamical system to compute the
solution until a given say time capital
T I can query uh the DL ROM online for
any time in the say training range I
would say
um we we avoid expensive iPad reduction
techniques this is another say good
achievement but on the other hand uh in
this say setting the DL ROMs still
require a quite expensive training stage
if that the size of the full order model
NH is is very large this is because we
need to reduce amount data from a
dimension and age to a very small
Dimension but the problem the bottleneck
is is NH and then we we move to a say a
sort of
um
somehow we we we we decided to to to
take that the best features of DL ROMs
and pod uh to somehow couple them to uh
say design these new pod DL ROM
architecture this means that the first
layer somehow that the first
dimensionality reduction is somehow
performed through pod no matter if the
dimension of the period space here is
quite large or even larger than say what
expected if only relying on on pod
because then once we say perform a first
reduction say from 1 million of degrees
of freedom to 10 000 then we can apply
to the Pod projection of the snapshots
data the DRM Machinery we have just
introduced so somehow we we leverage on
say both good features that dlram has to
say perform an incredible dimensionality
reduction uh say until the the parameter
Dimension say uh and what pod is able to
do uh in order to say uh perform a a
linear dimensional introduction that in
in this case is only say the the first
say uh reduction layer somehow uh so uh
notation is slightly different but the
the idea at the end is uh say the same
as before we want to match some of the
two uh the the the two letter that you
have in Gray here so the projection in
the Purity space and the Reconstruction
of them and then the two say low
dimensional representations that say
come out of the encoder and of this deep
photoreal Network so yeah I have a
question so if you do that and
um probably you want the Pod basis size
to be pretty big because the overall
accuracy will be bounded by the plot
absolutely yeah yeah you're totally
right uh in in the cases I mean I'm
going to show indeed uh of course the
the dimension of the Pod can be quite
large but somehow this is already say a
sort of reduction compared to the the
initial size say an age of the of the
fluorter model so no matter if say the
beauty Dimension is one thousands or ten
thousands well if you start from data
that live in a 1 million Dimensions
because of this very fine discretization
uh this is already say yeah a good
achievement but of course yes you're
solid right here so that the Pod
Dimension somehow uh um bounds somehow
the the the final accuracy of of this I
don't want to say that this is the only
say way to go but at least this was a
one of the most straightforward options
we we try to uh this is not the only
ingredient uh we also relied on
randomized SVD to further reduce
computational times and also on a sort
of say pre-training strategy in which we
decided first to train a model for a
simpler task and then using that trained
model to to initialize the second
training on the more complex task that
we need to to face for instance we we we
try to to change the constitutive law
and then to to start to say training a
network by relying on a simpler
constitutive law regarding for instance
examples in computational mechanics and
then say passing to them
say consecutive law we wanted or we also
try to learn uh say the the Nets on a
smaller range in time and then say
perform a second training for the final
time range we we want it these are some
results uh in which indeed also this
sort of pre-training shows that the
total time regarding training can be
further reduced from one hour to say 15
minutes this is quite a simple example
of say
um computational mechanics we have
elastodynamics of this simple beam
structure at the very end the the
testing can be can be performed in a
very very uh fast time uh similar
results in collaboration with say a
project regarding say the the modeling
of say of the the cardiac activity here
we have cardiac electrophysiology on a
ventricle on top on an Atrium here at
the bottom uh and here you have
parameters that are related once again
with the position of stimuli these are
simulations that takes more than three
hours of for say a finite element for
other model of course we need to pay
more than say one day regarding say the
construction of snapshots and then say a
first reduction one hour of training of
this periodial ROM but all this allows
us to perform online evaluation for new
say locations regarding say that the
release of the stimulus in say in a
scale that is indeed real time because
this is more or less the the scale
regarding time this phenomenon say
actually takes takes place and the same
say for for an Atrium in which a
simulation Time online is less than 0.2
seconds
um these are
so somehow people Rams allows us to get
say even faster or say as fast as real
time Solutions
these are results regarding fluid
dynamics the techniques is extremely
General because it only relies say on on
data extracted from from simulations and
then we we also enjoyed say the use of
this technique on different physical uh
say problems here you have the usual
Benchmark for foreign
for new parameter values can be very
quickly computed uh this is say the flow
uh sorry this is still the flow pasta
cylinder in which we also have the
approximation not only of the Velocity
but also the pressure provided of course
pressure data are available and given to
the to the network so everything can be
easily generalized also to the case in
which you have more than a single
variable to to approximate uh and also
the evaluation of outputs is indeed is
indeed very accurate this is what
happens in the case of a more involved
fluid flow this is a a blood flow in
cerebral aneurysm geometry where the
parameters are related with the the
inflow in time so here you have the
comparison of the Florida model
Affinity elements the poddl ROM here at
the middle and the error that is order
of 10 to the minus 5 taking of course
the comparison between the two and if
you look at the say at the flow pattern
into into the aneurysm in video you
cannot say find so so big differences
you have this reported in at the bottom
and then we could continue this is an
example related with fully structure
interaction uh where we have the usual
say uh solid deformation of of this
elastic beam attached to a to a fixed
the rigid Square block and this is the
the velocity say pattern regarding say
the floater model on the left and to
different say cases and then the
corresponding pod dl-ram approximation
so no matter if say also the the
complexity of the problem maybe say
increases a little bit there are no big
substantial changes in the architecture
of the piodial ROM
um and also in the case of back field
variables essentially the different
variable components can be can be
grouped together and then treated say
and by by a pure detail from
last but not least we also applied this
to to that to the analysis and the
simulation on the mechanical behavior of
this microelectromechanical systems uh
these are say tiny components that you
that you can find for instance in any
smartphone we we have in our in our
pocket uh so micro mirrors or things
like that where you the interest is to
characterize the so-called frequency
response function because you have say
loading on these structures describing
terms for instance of amplitude and
frequency parameters and then you want
to assess for instance the maximum say
deflection of these uh components that
features some internal uh geometric
non-linearities in the in the way these
deforms and at the end you can for
instance evaluate say a lot of
combinations regarding different say
frequencies and and an amplitude of the
loads somehow in in a in a couple of
minutes and what what that say a Florida
model would have required more Bond than
uh than I hear because of the need to to
say to to to perform very long long time
say simulation in this context
so this was say everything regarding say
the first part of course there are also
some say uh uh extensions further
extensions more aspects regarding both
time extrapolation if you want to go
beyond say the the time window in which
you you have observed data we somehow
try to rely on Long shorter memory
networks to to perform say time
extrapolation and we also introduce a
sort of mesh informed layers to take
into account the fact that indeed the
data we are dealing with say
um
are related to a computational mesh
where we perform say the computations to
get those snapshots and somehow we
decided to say sparsify the structure of
a network by taking into account uh say
the connected matrices uh the
relationships essentially between among
the vertices of the mesh so somehow we
were also be able to to make the the
neural network structure geometry aware
and this can be somehow an alternative
say a way to perform uh say a further
reduction in in the training uh to to
the Pod we introduced before so now here
we decided to to set to zero a lot of
weights and biases in our networks as
amount those that are related with
interactions among say points that in in
the mesh are very far from each other
and these of course have a strong impact
say also on the on the training say
performances of that kind of say
architecture so the details are on those
two archive prepares if you are
interested in you can have a look so
this is the end of the say first part
the second and third part of course will
be say shorter than the first one so
don't worry about that uh in the second
part uh if you don't have say questions
regarding this first part otherwise you
can take here a short short break and
then I can ask it to your question if
you have
yeah so um there are questions from from
chat room but there are many so okay
let's hear it maybe we wait until the
end of the okay okay yeah okay so in the
second part somehow we try to take
advantage of this framework to perform
say uh operator approximation so so now
we uh we know that as soon as we perform
the construction of projection based
reducer the models sooner or later you
need to take into account hyper
reduction to be able to assemble
nonlinear terms for instance in an
efficient way so that very often and
this is a case that we found for
instance in computational mechanics
where we have say quite involved in a
linear constitutive laws for for the
material it might be the case that the
Pod Dimension is quite small because say
the parameter to solution map is quite
say is good regarding the reducibility
through a linear Subspace but what is a
often annoying is the fact that those
say operators at the reduced level
require say a lot of say basis functions
to be to be approximated in the case you
rely for instance on the discrete
empirical interpolation okay so in a
linear case in which you need to rely on
a say reduce Newton problem uh for
instance a Newton iteration teach time
step if you do everything fully implicit
well you you end up with say an hyper
ROM where say your Jacobian matrix JN
and your use residual are and say must
be approximated on a given basis and the
basis must be computed through snapshot
starting from snapshots of their
nonlinear terms of the residuals and
then of the linear jacobians this means
that if you don't have a sufficiently
rich approximation in terms of operator
approximations also say that the overall
Newton iterations can be for instance
not converging or you might generate of
course large large errors then
accumulating time so in these slides I
just recalled for those of you who are
less acquainted say with uh for instance
discrete and political interpolation how
this somehow looks like you you want to
perform a linear approximation of the
residual and then you take the realities
to to have the Jacobian approximation
and then at the selected set of points
it's called Magic points in the initial
paper by madanko authors you have to set
a certain number of interpolation
constraints to match say the reduced
representation with the ones that you
would obtain by only looping on those
elements on the on the initial mesh this
is of course extremely intrusive
procedure
um so we decided to uh to to to see if
say did neural networks could also be
used to perform operator approximation
uh so somehow the pyramnet the technique
we ended up with is uh a
production-based technique in which say
The Operators at the reduced level
meaning the residual and the Jacobian in
the ROM are approximated through the
dl-ram approach we introduced before so
somehow rather than using snapshots of
the solution I say use snapshots of
residual vectors and Jacobian matrices
already at the reduced level so this
means that these are quite small
dimensional data because in those cases
the pld dimension is quite small
regarding the solution approximation and
then I perform the training of the same
networks we saw before to be able online
to compute uh reduced vectors regarding
the residual and reduce matrices
regarding the Jacobian by simply
evaluating uh online testing stage
another net
uh I skipped those details because it's
becoming say quite late you can find
them on the paper but the message is the
same kind of architecture so an out
encoder plus a fit for a neural network
is what indeed can be used also to
perform
operator approximation here there are
some results in which indeed the the
speed up is remarkable if if operators
are approximated through through neural
networks uh what what is what is good in
this case is that errors in time of
course that do not grow more than say
what the global errors regarding both
POV reduction and Hyper reduction did
and here you have some some example for
instance regarding say a beam case in
which you have say a parameter
dependence by the module of the
structure for instance and then we also
perform some analysis regarding both the
impact of the training sample size of
course you need say sufficiently uh
large samples to to train the networks
and also which is the impact on the Pod
dimension for the solution approximation
and similar results were obtained on a
slightly more say involved casing which
you have the contraction of an extremely
idealized say ventricle disease actually
half an ellipsoid a light geometry also
in this case the errors regarding say
both pod projection for the solution and
then these operator approximation do not
say grow in time with say remarkable
speed UPS compared to a to a full order
model and to a pod Larkin dime
reduceorter model
so now in this case what was really
limiting say the efficiency of the ROM
was the hyper reduction stage because
the the Pod reduction is already quite
good in order to say uh drastically use
the dimension of the of the solution
space and this was the reason why we
actually took advantage of say uh DL
ROMs to perform say operator
approximation
third and last part uh remember we
started from the need of approximating
the solution then we move to the
operator approximation and last but not
least how to take into account neural
Nets to perform uh output approximation
in a sort of multi-fidelity framework
um
so the goal is to approximate in this
case a high fidelity model fhf
leveraging few data possibly few data
from the heavy-duty model and several
data from the low Fidelity model so for
time being we only have two fidelities
and we explored essentially three uh
options a sort of intermediate option
where we directly model the High
Fidelity function training a sort of
all-in-one Network that takes both low
Fidelity and I feel it data and
considering the low Fidelity output as a
sort of intermediate level in this
a sort of two-step approach in which we
first learn say the relationship between
say the low Fidelity and the High
Fidelity data in case of course we have
both on a limited say amount of samples
and then we say somehow try to learn the
um
say we start sorry first to learn the
low Fidelity model from the input of the
low Fidelity model to the output the
develop output and then we take
advantage of this approximation and then
we give to a second Network that somehow
puts together the available High
Fidelity data and say artificially
generated High CC data from this first
Network this was the second option a
third option so now uh I did a third
network in between two models and now
the linear correlation between the High
Fidelity and the low Fidelity data in a
sort of say incremental approach in
which you you start by by learning say
the the linear correlation among them
and then you focus say more on the
output correction that you that you need
we took advantage of those say
architectures to for instance rely on
poor reduced on their model
approximation suppose that you have say
a periodical Larkin a registered model
this is a CD elements case uh depending
on some parameters say the wave number
the angular frequency
and some geometrical parameters
regarding say the shape of These
acoustic horn we want to in this case
evaluate an output quantity of Interest
so we are not interested to the whole
say a solution field but only to a to an
output of interest and then we have a
low Fidelity model that is given by a
periodical Larkin dime but for instance
you you may rely on a poor dime
approximation if you don't want to say
rely on very rich operator approximation
or on a poor pod basis for whatever
reason the high Affinity data are the
ones that comes from the our Fidelity
simulation finite element say
these are results regarding for instance
what happens in the case say different
sizes in terms of basis function so the
different fidelities of the low Fidelity
model somehow and different amount of
isolated data somehow combined to give
you at the end of the day say the
approximation of the of the output and
our findings were that say this sort of
two steps or three steps way to combine
data uh where say much more accurate
than say that intermediate structure
where all the data were seen by the
network in uh in um in a single shot I
would say the size of the news base is
clearly impacts on the accuracy of the
low Fidelity output the the high related
output is in Black
it's clear that if their use basis only
contains very very few bases the output
is a totally different story this is
extremely inaccurate nevertheless the
message is at the end no matter if the
low Fidelity output is not as accurate
as desired a multi-fidelity framework
can somehow combine together a lot of
low Fidelity output and few very
accurate High Fidelity output
so only few reduce basis functions are
considered to deal with a potentially
inaccurate or very inaccurate
profitability model clearly as soon as
the Affinity data say increase or basis
functions increase predictions are
better
uh the the intermediate model as as poor
predictive accuracy uh without a
sufficiently accurate low Fidelity model
but this was not the case uh of a
two-step or a three-step models uh so
you can be a bit safer regarding say the
uh the the poor uh Fidelity of the
locality model if you say uh combine
those two step or three steps and then
we decided to to extend these are more
recent results to extend these two time
dependent outputs uh somehow uh um
injecting here uh lstm cells so once
again suitable uh narrow letters that
take into account also that the time
dependent Behavior because what we
realized is that say by simply
considering those uh architectures with
time dependent data was not enough to
get very accurate prediction of time
dependent output so at the end of the
day the architecture we considered as
the same but now feature also layer are
here that take into account lstm
networks and I skip these results for
instance well I only say briefly here
you have a a problem where you have a
low dimensional dynamical system a lot
of one with three species or
three-dimensional dynamical system where
somehow we have low Fidelity data on a
quite long range High Fidelity data on a
say on a short range and here you have
the comparison between a single Fidelity
say lstm model but only related on low
Fidelity data well the the shift somehow
in say the frequency also say is
observed if you rely on Affinity data
well the accuracy is good as soon as you
have Affiliated data but in in the time
ranging with in where you only have a
lovely data while the prediction gets
worse and worse well a wise say
combination of say low fidelity data
potentially inaccurate but available and
few Affiliated data allows on a for
instance two-step architecture featuring
lstm layers to get say accurate
prediction of the output also say in the
time range in which activity data are
not available
so here you have the error between say
the true what we want to approximate and
what we obtain on the first row we only
have single Fidelity say architecture so
this means that as soon as you use lstm
well situation improves but if we
only rely say on low Fidelity data well
clearly the situation is is quite is
quite bad
using lstms on High Fidelity data is
good but the point is that affiliate
data can be can be very few so what
happens in in a multi-fidelity case well
in a multi-fidelity case without
lstms well the situation is not good as
desired because you have say quite large
errors and in this second row say second
third and fourth picture you have the
say the good errors that are obtained
for instance by relying on a two-step or
even better a three-step say
architecture featuring than lstm
layers so lstm layers allow us to take
advantage of this multifidality
framework to perform also evaluation of
time dependent outputs leveraging say on
few iplt data and say possibly many more
low Fidelity ones
so to conclude uh I I hope to say to her
to have been able to show that say deep
learning enhance their disorder models
uh say can can be of help uh provided I
satisfied this ad accuracy uh provided
we are able to control the computational
effort to say tackle some of the
problems that are listed in in those
bubbles so different physical different
physics-based models uh potentially I
mean we could use these these other
models to face several many query
scenarios so that the keywords is reduce
order modeling at large in all those
cases
um of course you may ask what happens
regarding the need of ensuring physical
constraints all what I've shown before
this movie here at the bottom somehow
was taking into account physics only
through the snapshots data but we are
currently working uh and maybe say now
next time you're in say a few months in
the future I will be also able to to
shows in a more structured way some
results for which we already have
initial results here you have say that
the forecast for instance in time after
say uh the time range in which we
observe the data uh without say a
physics based terms and we have found a
good way the details are still a bit
under investigation regarding say the
possibility to inject also physics in
this kind of architecture and you
usually see that situation regarding
time forecast say out of the say
training window is is much better so
more results we hope will follow soon I
stop here I list in this slide some some
references if you are interested in of
course please have a look or drop me an
email if you want to have a more detail
and I leave you with some of the picture
you could take from exactly this window
here uh my back say yeah a couple of
hours ago this is our campus and Milano
the city center is is on the back so
thank you very much for your kind
invitation and your attention thank you
you so much for the wonderful talk while
it is a real picture you just taken on
on our goal right
yeah this was here did this is what
actually I can can look from saying the
wind of my office this is our campus all
right sounds good okay so we have a um
many questions to cover there there are
many questions in in chat room let me
actually try to find the various uh
all right it's the first question is
from John
um
Texas A M and he has the in the very
very beginning you have a slide about
the you know the physics space then data
driven slides yeah you show that RB
methods to be high on the physics axis
but low on the data driven access but
I'll be methods collecting
snapshots and discover the RB spaces so
they would be data driven techniques as
well can you clarify I agree I agree
with uh with John actually of course
this was a possible way to conveying in
a single slides of course the the
pluralities of different techniques
somehow my focus was maybe more on the
way uh reduce order model and then a
result that approximation is generated
uh I totally agree with you about the
fact that of course these are say also
data driven techniques in the sense that
of course we need to take advantage of
snapshots of our Florida model to
generate the disorder approximations but
somehow the way in which the reducer
their model is built still takes into
account say the physical problem we
started from so in this sense somehow I
put say uh at the very say top of these
slide say reduce basis methods also
because this is the kind of techniques I
started from say some some years ago but
I totally agree with them yeah I I guess
it's it was a relative measure
all right the another question from John
isn't there also a parameter dependent
latent representation that one needs to
learn between the Pod and the TL stages
uh let's say
um so far we dealt with say
um say a quite limited number of
parameters if this is the question
valuation so we already have say
physical parameters that affect say the
problem that could also potentially be
related with geometrical say variations
but somehow these are our input
parameters so if the question is related
with the need of learning also sort of
parametric description of the inputs uh
this would be say another maybe Layer
Two to be added
the representation that on the other end
is learned for instance by the feed
forward neural network is intrinsically
parameter dependent because these
actually say a way to map say parameters
and time if I have time to these low
dimensional say space of the of the
Latin variables
um
so I hope to to advance for to to John
question all right sounds good
um okay
um
question about the uh
question from the Rob uh what about a
chaotic system how well does this
approach deal with the chaotic systems
like well we we would like to know uh on
how it of course performs say on more
and more involved cases
um of course this is a true Challenge
and this is still an open challenge to
me it's a predicting forward in time say
regarding the the the the the range in
which you collected the snapshots data
is already say quite challenging for
non-charactic say dynamical systems and
then I can imagine that the kind of
difficulty you you may find in the case
of say extrapolating forwarding times or
forecasting essentially the solution of
the problem out of the say uh training
range just for small time forecast uh
another maybe a key task that is related
to this is the fact that we could also
be interested potentially in uh say
extrapolating the behavior of the
solution out of the parameter range in
which we collected the data so somehow
the network learns say what the data
bring as as information of course we we
cannot say imagine to be able to
approximate unless we provide new
physics inspired or physics informed or
driven terms into this this procedure
maybe that can say play an essential
role in order to shut some light say on
possible say I don't want to say chaotic
system but say less smoother less
regular Dynamics already for instance a
periodic say systems already say
position some small challenges maybe but
some challenges well I just wanted to
say like the cardiac stuff since you
already have cardiac simulations yeah
it's pretty easy to drive the cardiac
stuff into a chaotic space
as soon as I say you you have say spiral
waves that say somehow break down uh
essentially we we add the results I
didn't put uh yes see you your common
thanks uh thanks about this uh actually
your comment allows me to to to say
something more we essentially dealt with
with a case where we had say that the
breakup of those say spiral waste fronts
uh in that case indeed uh we were able
to approximate the solution at least in
the time range in which we collected the
data so uh supposing that the data were
already reflecting that kind of behavior
so break up say of those uh say France
we were able to reproduce them for new
parameter values but in that let's say
time Windows this is this is for sure
true so at least say in this case there
is there is much hope thanks for
remarking this all right sounds good
um can we go back to John's question
like his second question about the
parameter dependent uh representation so
unfortunately he he does not have a
microphone available so he's relying on
the chat
I wish he he can just intervene and ask
her but he just gave me the
clarification the question is more about
the latent code that live in between pod
and and the Deep learning stages okay
yeah these indeed also somehow reflects
say the parameter dependence somehow the
network is trained by taking into
account data that have been computed for
different parameter values so somehow in
that case you are representing you are
attempting to represent
the structure of the solution manifold
essentially as pod does
when pod is applied to uh to a bunch of
net puts say computers for different
parameter values so in that case you are
somehow coding with that say latent
representation uh say that the whole
solution manifold that is intrinsically
parameter dependent right and then of
course for any new parameter value I
need to find and this is the second part
of the drum architecture I need to find
a way to connect say time and parameters
to the low dimensional code
uh so I up to 12 say better clarified
maybe it's aspect to to Jean but if this
is not the case of course we can keep on
discussing yeah I I guess you guys can
exchange email and then yeah you know oh
sure
yeah sounds good okay next question is
by Jesse from Stanford uh she's asking
since this approach you know she's
talking about the Pod yeah yeah since
this approach still uses pod data how
does this approach better approximate
problems with large homograph and myth
good good point let's see
um somehow uh we took advantage of pod
as already Yang Soo was mentioning
before with this question
um of course to to enhance even more say
the the reduction that is carried out
through a linear technique like pod
indeed for instance already it's a
cardiac electrophysiology for instance
uh is already a problem where the the
kolmogaro and width Decay is pretty bad
is very slow because of that say quite
complicated parameter to solution
dependence right uh so the partial say a
conclusion we have reached so far is
that we can afford for dealing with say
quite large Purity spaces
uh and you you may think to to to to
take into account say sufficiently large
pod spaces
um
a PD Dimension that would be totally say
uh ineffective if that was the only
reduction stage like in a periodic way
no matter if that pod space is quite
large dimensional well the the dl-ram
Machinery somehow then further reduces
dimensionality so for the time being the
only say personal author I totally agree
with you this is not say a complete
answer uh is to try somehow to uh rely
on sufficiently large dimensional Beauty
space or we haven't tried yet to rely on
maybe local pod spaces that was already
a way to say tackle uh the the problem
of the of the slow decay of the column
of government with but I totally agree
with you that this is a say a a quite
open issue yeah right great next
question is by evening
he asked well the second option of
mfnn are the structures of the second
neural network the neural network for LF
and neural network for HF the same if
not with the HF neural network more
complicated than
uh
say
um these are the dance Nazi in both
cases then all the details regarding for
instance the the construction in terms
of complexity of the of the
architectures are reporting the paper so
please have a have a look on that
um I would say uh the uh the goal of the
two Nets is slightly different because
the first net needs to learn the
relationship between the input and the
low Fidelity output
the second net uh acts more like a
correction by say bringing low Fidelity
outputs to High Fidelity output so the
first Nets so the the tasks uh the two
Nets must perform are intrinsically
different the one is more an input
output say a learning task the second is
more say a sort of conversion between
low Fidelity output to harsh data
outputs so the structure is slightly
different we then say perform a certain
kind of training in the in in in in in
in in the paper so also all the details
regarding the the procedure we followed
for the training are reported there uh
motif of course you still have say more
detail than and questions related to
this of course feel free to write me and
then we can we can exchange ideas on
this as well awesome sounds good okay uh
great we don't have any other
question in chat room it's I mean it's
past the 11 already I don't it's a it's
an ATM over there right he's 20 you know
he's eight he's eight p.m
yeah well thank you for
staying late with us very gracious
um from your side uh thank you uh well
uh let's wrap up
um so let's thank our speaker today for
the wonderful talk and if you have more
questions please feel free to email him
uh email Andrea Andrea directly I'm here
he's going to be happy to answer any
questions yeah it is my email address
indeed pay attention to this one that
follows my name unfortunately Andrea one
dot manzoni dot pull me dot at polymy.it
thanks to you young once again for for
this a very kind and an invitation I I
liked a lot and I enjoyed a lot to to
give this presentation hopefully say we
will be in touch and feel free of course
to write me how many told that people
attended for any kind of say question
sounds good thank you thank you so much
okay have a nice day all right bye bye